[Music]
hello and welcome to the session on
DevOps workflow in this session we will
understand what a workflow is how it is
applicable for a particular software
development project and what are the
various tools that can be used to create
the workflow workflow allows you the
ability to create a complex set of
repeatable tasks it's like a sticky
wrapper in the DevOps continuous
delivery that holds it all together for
you workflows work as a glue between
various processes and systems while
allowing you to easily track their
progress
imagine having perfect test automation
scripts but no easy way to execute them
outside of constructing a new build or
having a perfect CMDB integration script
but no way to call them outside of the
build process or even worse having a
need for human approval before a
deployment takes place and no way to
integrate it outside of a custom
deployable process our usual software
development cycle looks something like
this
developers need a pre-configured
environment with all the latest services
running that is consistent and the same
for each of the developers on the whole
team developers check in their co-ed in
the git repository from where it picked
up and the build is run you deploy the
latest release of the software
application to a temporary server deploy
your test harness to test your software
application and after all tests are
complete just get rid of that server and
environment set up your production
environment and deploy the latest
release of your software application to
prod accordingly send off notifications
at each of the steps noting the
completion status success and failure
these are the tasks we do in our
day-to-day in our project work
operations this is what we call a
typical SDLC project cycle with a few
variations here and there
when you are designing a workflow try to
break down automation constructs into
logical functions that are intended to
provide build automation for example you
should not include turning monitor
functions on or off something like a
build automation also should not have to
worry about the deployment process its
primary singular purpose is to construct
a new build where in that new build is
then deployed and becomes a single
purpose of the deployment process
attempting to automate the entire cycle
of an application into one automation
construct from end to end instead of
having small blocks that work together
increases the size of it which increases
the risk and increases the runtime which
makes it difficult to debug if there is
any problem also doing so takes away the
ability to run any one of these steps if
you want to rerun them at any point when
you are planning for a workflow a broad
overview can get you started on
assembling your workflow from the top
down the most important point when it
comes to planning your flow is that you
actually do it making a good plan before
you start a workflow will end up saving
a lot of time and heartache in the long
run when you are planning a workflow
drawing out the flow to help you
visualize the flow logic or writing out
a sketch in some textual form like
swimlane concepts can be great ways to
help identify what systems are involved
and what it's doing
using placeholder steps as you gradually
build up your flows interconnecting
parts let's take a moment to talk about
human intervention in a typical workflow
that we follow for software development
life cycles every time you are ready to
do a build you have to seek approvals
you have to seek sign offs you have to
wait for the people to be available to
come to a meeting to come to checkpoints
if you have automated your workflow and
every time you have to pause your
automation to obtain a human approval
you are unnecessarily introducing time
delays that cannot be predicted or occur
with any kind of consistency
similarly imagine a deployment process
that required a human to press yes
before continuing the introduction of a
human approval can sit idle on a tooling
screen for hours during lunch or any
unexpected days off or the person being
on vacation automate processes with such
quality and consistency so that the
human intervention could merely become
redundant and unnecessary workflow
rapper is a highly functional tool to
allow you to redesign more effective
automation processes limiting human
interaction where possible again the
goal is to build small independent
automation constructs that work together
in a highly efficient manner when you
sit down to create a workflow keep a
rule of thumb in mind that a big
workflow is a bad workflow big flows are
hard to create hard to read hard to test
hard to maintain and even hard to use
when you are creating a workflow break
down the large flow into smaller more
manageable units that can flow
themselves each unit can have a single
well focused purpose if you narrow down
the scope of each of the flows
components you basically make each
component easier to test and easier to
fix when something goes wrong or perhaps
needs updating smaller less complex
units are easier to test independently
and every time you have an iterative
task ask yourself if this can be done in
parallel instead of basically doing the
same work and in lesser time if you have
smaller chunks of manageable work then
you can actually make them run in
parallel rather than waiting for the
sequence to run when you are creating
workflows consider your error handling
minimize errors and make your debugging
as easy as possible start your flow with
an initialization step that would
basically sanitize all parameters before
they are being used in your workflow
handle all possible null values that
could possibly arise results like
success and failure are simple and easy
to understand use a more robust set of
rules that will impart a bit more
information as to what exactly what
when you are creating a workflow take
care of the notifications notifications
can also be handled in workflow wrapper
much better than an individual DevOps
tools for example a release manager
wanted to know the build processes for
his or her application would have to
build a notification method embedded
within build processes in order to know
if the build passed or failed an
alternative is the workflow wrapper just
check the build logs and you can send
notifications in the preferred method
whether it's email a text message or
even an Instagram picture additionally
one may not check the status of each and
every build created they may want to
know only when a build gets passed and
is ready for further testing
environments even departmental
notification escalation chains can be
incorporated easily in a workflow
wrapper and executes as expected but not
within each DevOps tool when you are
creating a workflow definitely consider
release management your release
orchestration tools have some minimal
workflow capabilities built into their
offerings most of the release management
tooling is designed to put an elegant
wrapper around the build automation and
deployment processes and it has the
ability to segment by line of business
or product as well as role based access
controls for permissions and edit
auditory complaints what release
management excels in our human
interactions and entire tracking
progress is of your release deployment
highly evolved notification systems tend
to require an external workflow wrapper
beyond the normal capabilities that a
release management tool can offer a
solid workflow wrapper acts as a glue
that can hold desperate DevOps tools
together
hey once become an expert in cloud
computing then subscribe to simpler
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos turn it up and get certified
in cloud computing click here